they went too
far we've made some powerful enemies
Daniel Patrol Fury Mrs Ford do I have
permission to go for it kill them all
mcdc God I love this program oh we're
hugging Now They Knew Too Much we have
one job here in the league to keep the
Lions out of the playoffs you told me
this draft class was a b at best Swift
trade the Gibs I just couldn't see it
you fool they played too fast hey keep
up that Rhythm kid and you keep playing
that sweet sweet bruise Against All Odds
he's ready sir the third franchise QB in
a ro for the pack this will surely take
down those disgusting
Lions just give me like one second to
get it together one Pride password
blueberries reporting for Duty again on
an impossible
mission who's out to get here the refs
the commiss the proo voters you know
everyone d man we get it to restore the
roar tonight we D on
RAM Detroit and the surrounding suburbs
versus everybody the Detroit Lions
in you stole my legacy go you stole mine
first hope you don't mind I still had
the key oh Detroit fans are getting stab
Standing Ovation what
[Applause]
[Music]
class they thought he was dead what no
I've been down the shore also I was on
the Jets last year forgotten by all you
all know I want a Super Bowl right
Mighty Joe old I'm